[Music]
there is something called a mutter of
motherhood penalty and essentially it
shows that a mother's earnings
dramatically decreased after having one
baby they continued to decrease after
two and three and four when you look at
father's and you look at those same
charts they're barely impacted in terms
of their in terms of their pay you know
some of this is tied really directly
with just generally the pay gap between
men and women in the United States the
irony of course is that when you look at
who actually performs well at work
women come back to work more capable
than they were before they left in many
many cases so they are they have an end
and end hard and stop to their day right
but this actually makes them more
efficient if they have been home and
leave if they've been home with a baby
on leave that baby has been the toughest
drill-sergeant boss you will ever have
in your life and has taught them to
pivot between tasks without really any
transition time between you know baby
needs one thing baby needs the next
thing you go you go you go you do and
that directly translate it's been shown
by women when they when they come back
to work they don't need transition time
between tasks so you hear a lot of women
say like oh I'm more efficient because
my day is shorter well actually they're
more efficient because they don't need
that kind of transition time between
tasks they compress things and they do
things really efficiently like actually
the real definition of efficient women
also sometimes like to say and I think
sometimes we undersell ourselves they
say Oh after Parenthood I am I am much
better at saying no to things and that
is true and that is that is valid but I
also ask the women who I speak to to to
turn that around as well so yes you're
better at saying no to things that don't
matter that aren't going to ultimately
benefit your company benefit your life
help you move you along in your career
fine however when a new working mom says
yes to something whether it is you know
going out with some colleagues you know
for a networking drink after work or it
is you know going for a big promotion
taking on a big new client when a new
working mom says yes to something she
has done that compromise already that
compromise math is what I call it in her
head to figure out how am I gonna make
this work what am I gonna steal time
away from so that I can say yes to this
so the by the time she gets to yes it's
an incredibly strong incredibly real
dedicated yes and I think that you know
so much of the way we present ourselves
coming back to work is requires an
internalization and an understanding
that of our strengths and of what we can
contribute to the workplace
[Music]